- you love googling yes sir now do you
google yourself I don't want to say okay
that would be narcissistic anxious you
google yourself I think the last one was
all I mentioned I did it once and I
would never do it again
Association all the whole idea behind it
well I don't know if you but if you
google there's a thing when you're
putting in a question it's so helpful
they try to finish your question for you
you don't based on the most popular
questions that have been asked in the
search engine so if we go to Google if
you put in why do men have nipples sky
blue why do cats purr
oh dear I why do I sweat too much far
too much bruise easily
green poop somebody said Bruce we is
equal to R T so much and then you will
have no friends see above why is right
there now
[Applause]
is that
my god is it wrong yet I think we passed
wrong a while ago
[Applause]
I love someone actually Bandra is it
wrong for a Christian to get a tattoo I
like - is it wrong with the blank you
can fill it in yourself ready I put it
in my guess so if I put in and usually
the strangest show I've ever been on
just watching him just play around on a
computer fantastic
Brad this is such a kind of you tell
what's going on in the world of moment
right
so as you're typing in when you get to
the end of Robert it's a pattern that
does not batson shower down just rally
smoke have kids
where does opportunity how much does
Robert Downey jr. way somebody wanted to
know that somewhere in the port the most
popular question about you want is
we've finished our silly game
[Applause]
[Music]
you